this is ghost fly hasn't been too long
has it yeah according to the watches we
don't have yeah it hasn't been long at
all
maybe if we gavrio watches we know how
long it's really bad so yeah we're just
gonna try it that it's not like before
we're just gonna try and do like five or
six hundred something like that and then
just keep coming back and do that every
week until we're all caught up so um
with that said a ghost fly by God so
much happens in this episode just so
much connecting to the grand story um
pretty much Jake kills a fly comes back
as a ghost they had to get rid of a be
end that's really about it okay you know
it was fun the way they did it um
peppermint Butler yeah peppermint Butler
comes back he gets he's in a very
briefly but pretty funny uh you know it
just draws these circles around him and
like everything he needs to defeat this
ghost flies in this bag that goes fly
not very quickly cuz it takes the bag
away and he just doesn't run out the
door he jumps through the window and
they find then the fly somehow I guess
infects or possesses Finn and that long
he forgot yeah I'm gonna forget a lot so
then um a mo see mo BMO no humo ah that
was it no arm oh so it has to stop
Jake's heart for just a little bit so he
can go to the ghost world to defeat the
ghost fly and he short story does do
that he introduced into the soup again
is unfinished business and then hit
before you can go to have any squashes
it should the kill me shouldn't try to
kill me son um and yeah then the doctor
princess brings him back but BMO takes
the credit of course and yeah that's
about it um it's fun it's you know just
a kilo waste of time I really do love
the idea of a ghost fly you never do
really think about like people always
come back sometimes even tasks of it you
don't think of
by coming back but in this one what I
love is all of them are draped in like
that you know the come together the
sheet but there's tables Lambeth yeah
look it was the super size yeah like all
these things I have a soul that we never
knew apparently the one thing I didn't
get or maybe I don't remember something
like that when Finn is making the circle
bigger
he draws an outline of a woman there
what's that supposed to be anything
unless I mean I don't I don't know I
just I said that was really weird that
he was doing that almost like he was
already pre possessed once he erased it
but then again I don't know um maybe
it's the girl I forgot her name that
lived in the tree house remember the the
ghost the one that was in the mansion
the well yeah that's right possible the
first thing I thought was like that
Island woman the woman I was literally
an island but it's again I don't know
what the connection would be um that's
why I like this show though there it may
be a connection is something or no
connection at all yeah it could just be
like nothing it's like I just happen to
draw an outline of a woman know it -
yeah that is so bizarre though and so
lacking a punchline than I really feel
like that it had to connect us okay now
hold on what was the punchline to Jake's
joke we never got to hear the punch line
- the joke really
really yeah you don't know what the
punch line - what do you call a bear who
only attacks a person named Paul is nope
really
no I've never even heard it and it you
know it people a line is something else
but Paul Bearer oh my god um I'm not
really you know fast on the whole joke
thing I was gonna say I I feel like half
the character's name so I'll just take
it as like even balance you know it's a
since it's a cute episode it's just sort
of it you know I wish perhaps it was a
a little faster on some of the jokes it
felt like it took a while to get going I
loved a little fly with the safe though
yeah I love the sound addicted whoo
these little poops on your soul that do
is very educational to about what flies
actually do when they land on food or
anything you actually really
legitimately do not want to fly to land
on anything as they do like all this
terrible like they'll puke can they
vomit on it yes all just back up and
then they vomit again they actually are
the most disgusting creatures in the
world like you really when you swat at
them you're doing a good thing
no more flies watch the fly David
Cronenberg's the fly yeah I was gonna
say that had to be like when fins
possess they had to be called back at
least to the original I would think it's
possible I mean eh I don't know what the
adding of the vomit and everything I'm
guessing that's more the remake that
made them maybe both through this me
because in the original it's like it's
it's just a fly yeah I know that's a fly
we're in like the remake it's like was
sort of a half lie half human something
in between whenever by the originals
like no it's just a fly so yeah trying
to think it I feel so weird it's like
you know we're back here we go that's
like what can you say about this episode
like that a ton I mean it's fine and I
love I thought it was super fun like
beemo with the actually what I was
expecting to come up and happen was
remember he had the restless leg
syndrome yeah yes circle when he said oh
oh if Jews wait a moment he starts
tapping his foot again I was waiting for
it to come back to the restless leg
syndrome but it never did would ya I
just mean I I sort of thought they were
really gonna do something with that too
because it was such a running I mean me
not running joke but they certainly kept
using it in the opening and like you
said sir I came back a little bit but
never really I had a punch line so
people come back another episode
adventure time who knows so uh yeah no I
did it's fine it's it's good for what it
is yeah so you know we should have done
put sheets over our heads and stuff then
people would think we're Klansmen which
we are I mean
little barbecue you note doesn't get
many visitors but the ones who chill out
there are quite special and really mean
you're gonna get in a lot of trouble
yeah